مرحبًا، أنا الدكتور سانجاي غوبتا مضيف
بودكاست Chasing Life على قناة CNN،
ربما سمعت ذلك قبل تناول المزيد من
الأطعمة الكاملة والقليل من الأطعمة المصنعة، ولكن ما مدى سوء
تلك الأطعمة المصنعة، فقد
تبين أنها سيئة جدًا، ومن
المعروف بالفعل أن الأطعمة فائقة المعالجة
ترفع من مستوى غذائك  خطر الإصابة بالسمنة
ومشاكل القلب والسكري والسرطان مما يؤدي إلى تقصير
العمر، لقد كنت
مهتمًا حقًا بالدراسة الحديثة التي
تظهر أنه إذا كان أكثر من 20 بالمائة من
نظامك الغذائي اليومي يحتوي على أغذية فائقة المعالجة فإن
خطر الإصابة بالخرف يزداد
والأشخاص الذين يتناولون كميات أكبر من الأطعمة فائقة المعالجة.
كان للطعام أسرع تدهور معرفي
أيضًا، والآن هناك حل واحد وهو طهي المزيد من الطعام، قم
بإعداد وجباتك الخاصة من الصفر
باستخدام الفواكه والخضروات
والبروتينات الصحية والحبوب الكاملة، وإليك
أيضًا الأخبار الجيدة إذا كانت
الجودة الإجمالية لنظامك الغذائي عالية مما يعني أنك
تتناول في الغالب تلك الأطعمة الكاملة  والوجبات
المطبوخة في المنزل ولكن بين الحين والآخر
تنغمس في بعض البطاطس المقلية على سبيل المثال،
يختفي الارتباط بين تناول الأطعمة فائقة المعالجة والتدهور المعرفي، تذكر أنه
لا بأس من الانغماس في تناولها من حين لآخر
طالما أنك تقوم بتعبئتها  مع
أشياء صحية جيدة في معظم الأوقات،
ويمكنك سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك ومطاردة الحياة أينما
حصلت على ملفاتك الصوتية
[موسيقى]